ihn habt ihr sicher schon mal gesehen
den q& nonchaman dessen Bilder beim
Sturm auffs Kapitol in Washington DC um
die Welt gegangen sind von diesem Sturm
bei dem trumpanhänger Joe bidens
Präsidentschaft verhindern wollten haben
fast alle gehört aber da steckte noch
mehr hinter der Schamane und die q&on
Community glauben nämlich dass die Welt
von einer geheimen satanistischen
Pädophilen Elite gesteuert wird die sich
mit Kinderblut verjüngt und Trump
versteht sie als Retter der endlich
dagegen vorgeht tatsächlich glauben dass
Millionen Menschen auf der ganz Welt und
zwar wegen einer Person die nennt sich
ganz schlicht tritt nur durch anonyme
online POS an die Öffentlichkeit und
soll vermeindlich aus dem ganz engen
Kreis von Donald Trump stammen soll die
Machenschaften und Verschwörungen der
geheimelite öffentlich gemacht haben das
klingt alles komplett wild aber von
Teilen dieser Geschichte habt ihr
bestimmt auch schon mal gehört im q& non
Mythus finden sich quasi alle bekannten
verschwörungserzählungen wieder
flatarther die Mondlandung 911 der Mord
an Kennedy der große Austausch Deos
haben wir uns hier auch schon mal
angeguckt und viele viele andere wir
reden hier über eine der größten
verschwörungserzählungen aller Zeiten
und man muss sagen q&on hat mittlerweile
sektenähnliche Züge angenommen und
Supporter auf der ganzen Welt was ihr
vielleicht nicht geahnt hättet sie
zweitmeisten davon leben in Deutschland
wir haben immer wieder gesehen dieser
verschwörungsglaube ist unglaublich
gefährlich auf der ganzen Welt gibt es
Verbrechen von q& non Fans aber wie zur
Hölle konnte es so weit kommen wie
konnte aus einem anonym Posting in einem
Onlineforum eine aber millionenfache
Anhängerschaft entstehen wir checken in
diesem Video woran q&on Fans glauben wie
der Mythos entstanden ist und wie
gefährlich qon werden
[Musik]
kann um den Mythos von q&on zu verstehen
muss man ins Jahr 2017 zurückgehen denn
ganz am Anfang dieser riesigen
verschwörungserzählung steht ein
einziger Post in einem anonymen
Internetforum und zwar auf dem imagebard
Fortun das sieht so so aus da können
Leute Texte und Bilder zu allem
möglichen posten was man häufig sieht
Gaming Anime Politik Pornos memes aber
auch krasse Gewaltdarstellung der catch
dabei es wird sehr wenig moderiert und
die Postings sind standardmäßig anonym
der erste Post vom User der sich später
den Namen gibt stammt vom 28 Oktober
2017 und der hat angeblich ganz heiße
News auf dem boord war behauptet worden
Hillary Clinton soll am 30 Oktober
verhaftet werden und dann kam
und lieferte eine detaillierte
Ausführung was danach passieren sollte
der Post geht ziemlich ins Detail falls
Hillary rthheim Clinton hier mit HLC
abgekürzt das Land verlassen wolle sei
bereits eine Auslieferung mit mehreren
Staaten vereinbart worden ab dem 30
Oktober nach Mitternacht sei ihr Ausweis
auf einer fandungsliste geführt es gebe
also einen Haftbefehl im Anschluss
würden massive Ausschreitungen erwartet
weitere Menschen könnten die Flucht
antreten die Marines und die US National
ge sein in Alarmbereitschaft als Beweis
dafür gibt der Post an man könne die
Nationalgarde fragen ob sie sich am 30
oktober in den meisten großen Städten
zum Dienst zu melden habe wir haben
leider kein Mitglied der Nationalgarde
für den nachträglichen proofcheck
gefunden was wir aber wissen Hillary
Clinton wurde am
30.10.2017 nicht verhaftet und schon gar
nicht vom US-Militär an der Stelle
könnte man jetzt meinen okay war Quatsch
halt irgendein Troll und die Sache ist
gegessen postet aber danach immer wieder
zwe Tage nach seinem ersten Post taucht
auch zum ersten Mal sein Name auf steht
für eine freigabestufe im
Energieministerium der USA Leute mit
clearance haben Zugriff auf die
geheimsten Infos z.B über Atomwaffen
geheimer und wichtiger geht es also kaum
ein paar Tage nach dem ersten Post
nannte sich Q noch Q clearance Patriot
später fing er an seine Posts mit zu
unterzeichnen und die Fallen ziemlich
unterschiedlich aus mal postet er
konkrete vorhersagen wie eben gesehen
die treten aber quasi nie ein Mal sind
es auch Erklärung warum seine
Vorhersagen noch nicht eingetreten sind
oder warum sie eingetreten sind es aber
gerade noch nicht danach aussieht und
manchmal ist es auch kompletter
Kleinkram
soll vorausgesagt haben was Donald Trump
twittern oder in der Öffentlichkeit
sagen würde z.B dass er am small
business Saturday das Wort small
twittern würde und das ist sogar
passiert durch solche Posts sollte es
näher zum damaligen Präsidenten bewiesen
werden man sollte meinen dass man für
solche Vorhersagen keine top secret
information bräuchte und trotzdem fanden
viele das ganze ziemlich reizvoll man
wird ja auch sonst nicht so oft in
geheime Angelegenheiten eingeweiht und
die Postings von hat sich eine immer
größere Community gebildet und für die
gibt es jede Menge
motivationsnachrichten und
Durchhalteparolen nicht nur von selbst
sondern auch von den Community
Mitgliedern der Satz where we go one we
go all wird zum Leitspruch einer für
alle alle für einen quasi follow the
white rabbit ist noch so ein leidspruch
der spielt auf das Kaninchen an das
Alisons Wunderland führt die kon
Anhänger sollen sich nämlich tiefer ins
rabbitall begeben und selbst forschen
zwischen 2017 und 2022 hinterlässt fast
5000 Postings sogenannte Drops diese
Drops werden dann von der Community
interpretiert gerade zu Anfang vor allem
von Leuten die zuvor schon durch ihre
Nähe zur extremen Rechten aufgefallen
sind die haben auf ihren eigenen Kanälen
die meistens sehr kryptischen
Nachrichten von quasi übersetzt und
daraus so eine Art inhaltliche Grundlage
für die Community geschaffen ihr seht
schon über Jahre in ist hier nach und
nach ein Mythos entstanden der baut auch
auf der Interpretation anderer User und
Schlüsselfiguren auf um die Inhalte und
die Bewegung besser zu verstehen haben
wir mit Josef hollenburger gesprochen er
ist in Deutschland einer der Experten
für q&on er beschäftigt sich seit Jahren
mit der Bewegung lie deren Kanäle mit
und hat 2022 mit dem ZAS eine Studie zu
q&on in Deutschland und Österreich
herausgegeben er hat uns erklärt wie die
Interpretation der sogenannten Drops oft
gelaufen ist in der Szene gibt es
tatsächlich Baker die bezeichnen sich
selbst so das sind Leute die aus diesen
kryptischen
Botschaften na ja aus diesen breadcrumbs
sagen sie eben halt fertiges Brot dann
backen das dischifrieren auf Youtube
dann teilweise stundenlange Videos
darüber machen was denn eigentlich mit
dem cu poost Nummer 3425 gemeint wäre
ein typisches Beispiel für die sehr
unterschiedlichen Möglichkeiten zur
Interpretation der Posts ist dieser C
Drop what is stake who has control
surprise witness was surprised who will
be surprised trust the
plan die drrops sind eben oft so
unkonkret dass man alles finden kann
wenn man nur will deswegen so eine Art
Meta verschwörungserzählung unter die
man alles mögliche mit reinzählen könnte
und es ist so eine Art Detektivarbeit
die da ganz mit drin steckt also man
könnte jetzt herausfinden was gemeint
hätte indem man z.B Symboliken sucht die
in den Nachrichten auftauchen oder wenn
man auf die Tweets von Donald Trump
guckt das war am Ende ja so eine Art
Mitmachgeschichte die daraus geworden
ist eine Analyse der Postings von zeigt
dass der größte Anteil der Drops wage
Anspielung auf ein angebliches
Geheimwissen macht eben auch durch
Suggestivfragen die dann wiederum von
der Community ausgelegt werden und immer
wieder heißt es trust the plan aber was
soll das für ein Plan sein die
Anhängerinnen und Anhänger von q&on
behaupten dass die USA nicht wirklich
von den gewählten Abgeordneten im
Kongress und der Regierung geführt
werden stattdessen sagen sie die wahre
Kontrolle hätte der deep state der Tiefe
Staat W genau sie dazu zählen ist nicht
ganz klar da gibt es keinen Konsens die
q&on Community ist sich aber sicher die
Geheimdienste viele Politikerinnen und
Politiker aber auch einflussreiche
Privatmenschen stecken unter einer Decke
jetzt kann man sagen okay weird aber
wenn das nur Leute im Internet behaupten
ja da gibt's halt komische Leute aber
auch Donald Trump hat vom deepstate
gesprochen mehr noch er hat 2018 als er
noch Präsident war sein eigenes
Justizministerium beschuldigt Teil von
deepstat zu sein Trumps Fans haben den
immer wieder als Grund genannt weshalb
politische Vorhaben unter Trump nicht
umgesetzt wurden außerdem werfen sie dem
deep state vor Wahlen zu manipulieren
aber warum soll ausgerechnet Trump der
Milliardär und Fernsehstar der zum
Präsidenten gewählt und damit der
mächtigste Mann der Welt wurde nicht
auch da drin hängen seine Wahl haben
viele Expertinnen und Experten für
unwahrscheinlich gehalten Leute aus der
Demokratischen Partei haben sich über
seine Kandidatur lustig gemacht genau
wie viele Medien ein Underdog der nicht
aus der Politik kam und trotzdem
Präsident wurde und versprochen hat die
Politik aufzumischen und das angeblich
korrupte Establishment zu entmachten
drain the swamp hieß das in seiner
Wahlkampagne das haben seine Fans und
dann auch die q&on Community als
sicheren Beleg verstanden dass Trump auf
keinen Fall Teil vom korrupten deep
state Establishment sein kann Trump
steht deshalb im Zentrum der q& on
Bewegung er ist quasi der Auserwählte
der mit dem deepstate Aufräumen soll an
dieser Stelle kommen wir an den Punkt an
dem man im Umgang mit vielen
verschwörungserzählungen irgendwann
landet mit Fakten zu belegen dass es
eine super geheime Elite nicht gibt ist
quasi unmöglich weil sie ja geheim ist
und das was an Informationen und Fakten
zugänglich ist ist für die Anhängerin
und Anhänger einer
verschwörungserzählung im Zweifel eben
von der Elite gefälscht währenddessen
werden Informationsfragmente von
Anhängerinnen und Anhänger solcher myen
nach Belieben interpretiert
weitergesponnen und verknüpft in q&r und
telegramgruppen werden z.B solche
Schaubilder über den deepstate
verbreitet und da wird so ziemlich alle
miteinander verbunden die Nazis der
Vatikan Zivilisationen in der hohlen
Erde künstliche Intelligenz freie
Energie Area 51 die Dialektik des
deutschen Philosophen Hegel der
Klimawandel Disney bei all diesen für
uns absurd klingenden Verknüpfungen muss
man trotzdem feststellen der deepstate
ist ein Erklärungsmuster das sehr viele
Dinge vereinfacht und runterbricht auf
den Kampf zwischen Gut und Böse mit dem
angeblichen deepstate als Machtzentrum
muss man sich dann nicht mehr mit
Nuancen auseinandersetzen und daraus
ergeben sich auch ganz konkrete Gefahren
sinnbildlich dafür ist dieser Fall am 15
Juni 2018 blockiert ein schwer
bewaffneter q&on Anhänger eine große
Brücke am hover staudarm in Arizona er
stellt einen gepanzerten Transporter
quer auf die Fahrbahn und da hält er
dann ein Schild hoch Release die oig
Report jetzt fragt ihr euch was für ein
Report kurz zurück in der Geschichte wie
gesagt die kon Erzählungen sind sehr
umfangreich und verschachtelt Anfang
2015 kam raus dass Hillary Clinton in
ihrer Zeit als US Außenministerin
teilweise ihre private Mailadresse für
geschäftliche Mails genutzt hat das FBI
und das Justizministerium haben
ermittelt aber kam zu dem Schluss dass
keine Anklage erhoben werden soll diese
Ermittlungen wiederum wurden vom oig
geprüft dem Department of justices
office of the inspector general eine Art
Abteilung für interne Ermittlungen im
Justizministerium deren Schlussbericht
kam zu dem Ergebnis dass Clinton in den
Ermittlungen nicht bevorzugt oder
benachteiligt wurde es also keine
politische Voreingenommenheit bei den
Ermittlungen gab dieser Report kam am 14
Juni 2018 raus also einen Tag vor der
brückenblockade
hatte diesen Bericht unglaublich gehyped
er solle angeblich beweisen dass das FBI
das Justizministerium und demokratische
Politiker illegal versucht hätten den
Wahlsieg von Trump zu verhindern das
stand aber nicht im Bericht und dann
und seine Community haben behauptet im
veröffentlichten Dokument könnte man
dass es geändert wurde an der Schriftart
und den Abständen Trump solle angeblich
den echten unzensierten Report haben
also mal wieder trust the plan wie soll
ein Report veröffentlicht werden den es
gar nicht gibt der tatsächliche oig
Bericht war ja da die qon Bewegung war
aber mit dem Inhalt unzufrieden und
wütend darüber dass Hillary Clinton
nicht verhaftet wurde wer glaubt gegen
eine so große Übermacht zu kämpfen die
die echte Wahrheit verschleiert der
sieht nur weniger Auswege die Aktion am
hustaudam war schlicht und einfach
Terrorismus Unbeteiligte wurden bedroht
um die Regierung zum Handeln zu zwingen
an diesem Tag ist der Mann nach einer
Verfolgungsjagd festgenommen worden es
hätte auch deutlich schlimmer ausgehen
können leider ist es das in der
Vergangenheit auch oft seit 2018 gab es
zahlreiche Straftaten die im
Zusammenhang mit q&on stehen darunter
sind Kindesentführung gewalttätige
Angriffe Tötung und natürlich der Sturm
aufs Kapitol in Washington DC wenn man
an q&on denkt ist man mit den Gedanken
meist direkt in den USA vergisst man
schnell dass der Mythos auch in
Deutschland weit verbreitet ist in
Deutschland sind nämlich immer wieder
Straftaten auf Einflüsse von q&on
zurückzuführen der Täter des
rechtsextremen und rassistischen
Anschlags in Hanau von Februar 2020 hat
in seinem Manifest q&onthesen wiederholt
der Sturm auf den Reichstag im Sommer
2020 lässt sich auch auf diese Einflüsse
zurückführen auf den Treppen des
Reichstages sind an diesem Tag jede
Menge q& non Symbole zu sehen gewesen
aber auch bei anderen Demos und
Veranstaltungen in Deutschland sind die
Symbole immer wieder präsentiert worden
Hintergrund warum das in Deutschland so
gut funktioniert hat ist es gab die
Vermengung mit der reichsbürgerszene
eine Szene die geglaubt hatte dass
Deutschland immer noch z.B durch die USA
durch die Alliierten besetzt wäre und
damit dann nicht nur geglaubt hätte dass
Donald Trump staatsüberhaupt der USA
wäre sondern eigentlich auch
Staatsoberhaupt Deutschlands so standen
dann auch Reichsbürger rechtsextreme und
die q&on Leute gemeinsam unter qflaggen
auf Querdenker dememos und vor dem
Reichstag übrigens einige Behauptungen
der Reichsbürger haben wir hier für Euch
gecheckt schon 2017 wurden die q&on
Erzählungen auch in Deutschland aktiv
verbreitet besonders schnell ist das
Ganze aber in Deutschland vor allem mit
der coronapandemie dann gewachsen also
Anfang
2020 weil sie vermutet haben dass die
coronapandemie vielleicht sogar durch
und durch Donald Trump genutzt werden
könnte um jetzt auch in deutschenland
Europa aufzuräumen und diesen
vermeintlichen deep state zu vernichten
und innerhalb von kurzer Zeit hatten
dann deutschbeige qnen Kanäle über 100
tausende Abonnenten und das ist offenbar
auf fruchtbaren Boden gefallen Anfang
2022 glaubten 7% der deutschen dass die
Politik von einer fremden Macht
beherrscht wird die im Hintergrund die
Fäden zieht das zeigt die repräsentative
q&on Studie vom zemas und immerhin 3%
stimmten der These zu dass die Regierung
die Medien und die Finanzwelt von
satanistischen Pädophilen kontrolliert
werden das klingt nach sehr wenig aber
das wären auf ganz Deutschland gerechnet
über 2 Millionen Menschen das sind
natürlich nicht alle organisierte q&on
Anhänger aber die Studie zeigt eine
bedenkliche Verbreitung dieser Annahmen
und auch bei der deutschen Szene hat man
gesehen dass sie ständig neue Dinge in
die Erzählung eingebaut hat man hat das
z.B gesehen während der
Flutkatastrophe im
artal in rinamfalz Nord westfahen dass
es da plötzlich wieder ja Menschen aus
der kzene gab die da wieder neue
Botschaften reinlesen wollten und wieder
eine riesige Reichweite hatten nach der
Flutkatastrophe im atil 2021 hieß es in
einem der größten deutschen
telegramkanäle der der q&on Bewegung
dass durch die Flut 600 Tote Kinder aus
einem geheimen untergrundlager gespüt
worden sein in der Hochphase von q&on
haben auch einige deutsche Promis q&on
Thesen verbreitet oder sich mit q&on
influencer gezeigt das waren z.B Michael
Wendler Nena oder xavia naidou qenon hat
neben dem Glauben an den Deep state noch
eine andere Prominente Vorstellung die
in der Bewegung von fast allen als
Wahrheit anerkannt wird die Sache mit
dem adrenochrom um das zu verstehen
müssen wir aber wieder zurückschauen
pizzaagate schon mal gehört kurz vor der
US-Präsidentschaftswahl 2016 also über
ein Jahr bevor es mit losging wurden
E-Mails von Hillary Clintons
Wahlkampfmanager veröffentlicht John
Podesta wurde gehackt wikileaks hat die
Mails dann ein paar Wochen vor der Wahl
online gestellt aus diesem Mail League
hat sich eine verschwörungserzählung
entwickelt pizzagate wer das für echt
gehalten hat dachte führende
Politikerinnen und Politiker sind in
einen kinderhandelsring verwickelt der
aus einer Pizzeria in Washington DC
gesteuert wird John Podesta hatte
Mailkontakt zu Pizzeria Comet mit
Pingpong da ging es um eine
Wahlkampfveranstaltung und eben um Pizza
auf for chen wurden diese Mails
uminterpretiert da wurde behauptet dass
Podesta mit Codewörtern arbeiten würde
und es beim Austausch über Pizza
eigentlich um Kindesmissbrauch und die
Machenschaften eines angeblichen
pädophilenrings um Hillary Clinton gehen
würde im Dezember 2016 hat dann ein
bewaffneter Anhänger dieser
verschwörungserzählung die Pizzeria
gestürmt unter anderem um ausschauen
nach Kindern zu halten die angeblich im
Keller der Pizzeria gefangen gehalten
wurden und was wirklich ironisch wäre
wäre die ganze Sache nicht so gefährlich
komm mit Pingpong hat gar keinen Keller
verletzt wurde zum Glück niemand
pizzagate lieferte aber eine inhaltliche
Grundlage für einen weiteren großen
Glaubenssatz der q&onanhänger achtung
jetzt wird's unangenehm die Bewegung
glaubt dass eine Elite aus Pädophilen
Satanisten Kinder in unterirdischen
Lagern hält um ihn dort adrenochrom zu
entziehen und sich selbst damit zu
verjüngen diese Elite besteht angeblich
aus Leuten aus der Politik Hollywood
Stars anderen medienpersönlichkeiten und
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer das ist
wieder eine glasklare
verschwörungserzählung die man nicht auf
Basis von Fakten prüfen kann ein
bisschen aufdröseln können wir das aber
zuerst adrenochrom ist ein Stoff der
wirklich existiert das hier ist die
Strukturformel und das ist eine Flasche
adrenochrom es ist einfach nur ein
Stoffwechselprodukt von Adrenalin
entsteht in unserem Körper und kann im
Labor hergestellt werden nur hat es
weder berauschende noch verjüngende
Wirkung ab den 50er Jahren wurde
erforscht ob adrenokrom für das
Auftreten von Schizophrenie
verantwortlich sein könnte aus dieser
Forschung kamen der Stoff und seine
vermeintlichen Wirkungen bei
verschiedenen Autoren an die sich mit
Drogen auseinandergesetzt haben auch bei
Hunter S Thomson der das ganze in seinem
Buch fear and lothing in Las Vegas
eingebaut hat schon während der
Hochphase von pizzagate wurde adrenocrom
mit dem angeblichen Kinderhandel in
Verbindung gebracht die pizzaagate
Anhänger haben das dann in die q&on
Community getragen der Ursprung dieser
verschwörungserzählung der isten sehr
viel älterer das ist die sogenannte
ritualmordlegende also dass Jüdinnen und
Juden christliche Kinder rituell
ermordet hätten um ihren eigenen Gott zu
huigen das sind uralte antisemitische
verschwörungserzählungen aus dem 12 13
jahrhundert die da immer wieder
aufgegriffen wurden man kann die Sache
mit dem adrenokom gar nicht ohne diesen
Bezug verstehen das antisemitische
narrativ hat sich kulturell festgesetzt
die vermeintlichen Täter also die
Politikerinnen und Politiker Stars und
andere werden entmenschlicht indem ihn
unmenschliche Dinge vorgeworfen werden
in Verbindung mit dem Glauben dass sie
Teil einer Elite sind die alles weiß und
alles steuern kann ist das richtig
gefährlich denn wenn Menschen das
glauben und sich gegen einen
vermeintlich übermächtigen und absolut
bösen Gegner auflehen wollen legen diese
verschwörungserzählungen so das
Fundament für Gewalt die kon Community
glaubt einem riesigen allumfassenden
Machtzentrum gegenüber zu stehen mit
ihrer Vernetzung ihrem Protest und am
Ende auch mit terroristischen Akten wie
dem stumm aufs Kapitol wollen sie ihre
gefühlte Machtlosigkeit in eine Art
Gegenmacht verwandeln josef holenburger
hat uns erklärt dass der q&onauben eine
ganz besondere Rolle für unzufriedene
Leute spielt man muss be so ein bisschen
wissen dass es ja erstmal eine Art
positive verschwörungserzählung ist im
Vergleich zu den anderen negativen also
da geht z.B bei den anderen negativen
darum dass es irgendwie keine Ahnung die
coronaimpfung zur Dezimierung der
Weltbevölkerung eingesetzt wird ein sehr
dystopisches Bild was da transportiert
wird und bei Q ist es eigentlich so dass
die Grundstruktur ja ist es gäbe einen
geheimen Plan der gerade durchgesetzt
wird von Personen wie Trump zur
Entmachtung des deep States und danach
kommt ein großes Erwachen gibt ein
goldenes Zeitalter das uns erwartet
danach wird alles gut und und das ist
etwas was sehr anziehend erstmal für
viele Menschen wirken kann der geheime
Plan mal wieder wenn die Community
glaubt dass Trump den umsetzt und sich
dann alle Probleme von heute auf morgen
lösen wäre das ja alles gar nicht so
bedenklich der Glaube an diesen Plan hat
aber einen Twist und hier wird es so
richtig gefährlich das dystopische
trotzdem an diesem Element ist sie
glauben dass das z.B nur nach 10 Tagen
Dunkelheit kommen würde das ist so ein
Begriff der innerhalb der Q Szene häufig
genannt wird 10 days of Darkness
bezeichnet eigentlich eine Art
Bürgerkrieg bei den sehr viele Menschen
sterben werden im Endeffekt freuen sich
sehr viele Menschen die an qon Glauben
auf diesen Bürgerkriege auf die
Vernichtung von Menschen auf die
bernichtung von dem was sie als
Feindbild identifizieren und je länger
Menschen in der qonzene aktiv sind desto
mehr können Sie irgendwann glauben dass
es auf Ihr persönliches Eingreifen
ankommt gerade der Sturm aufs Kapitol
und auch so ein bisschen der reichig
zeigen dass es da eben schon immer
wieder die Elemente gab wo die Leute
gedacht haben es reicht nicht nur auf
den Plan zu warten jetzt muss ich selbst
der Plan werden es muss selbst aktiv
werden und dann auch auf Gewalt
zurückgegriffen haben aber wie hoch ist
die Gefahr denn aktuell im November 2022
hat seinen letzten bekannten Post
abgesetzt das bedeutet aber nicht dass
mit ihm das Gefahrenpotenzial
verschwunden ist K ist auf keinen Fall
vorbei die Szene ist immer noch munter
dabei Inhalte zu produzieren und nicht
nur wird fleißig weiter auf telegram
gepostet 2024 gibt es die reelle Gefahr
dass die q&on Szene noch deutlich mehr
Zulauf finden und sich die Gefahr
verstärken könntewerken gerade wieder
dass me Menschen sich dem Thema QQ
widmen weil es z.B derzeit wieder
realistischer werden konnte dass Donald
Trump zur Wahl antreten könnte und
plötzlich meinen sie vielleicht war es
ja doch so dass geheime Botschaften
versteckt hat und die einfach nicht für
2020 golden sondern für 2024 und der
geheime Plan funktioniert doch also ist
selbst mit den Jahren nichtz bekommen
und das hat einen Grund auch wenn es er
2017 gibt die Inhalte dahinter sind zum
großen Teil nicht neu der qonmtos
verbindet rassistische antisemitische
und antidemokratische
verschwörungserzählungen die auch früher
schon ein Grund für Gewalt waren solche
Erzählungen kochen aber immer wieder
hoch q&on ist nur ein besonders
aktuelles und besonders umfangreiches
Beispiel durch den mitmachfaktor wurde
das zu einer riesigen Schnitzeljagd bei
der Menschen sterben man darf diese
Stories nicht unterschätzen egal wie
absurd sie klingen hattet ihr schon mal
Kontakt zu kon Fans und was für
Erzählungen machen euch Sorgen schreibt
uns das mal in die Kommentare und
vergesst nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren
hier gibt's regelmäßig background checks
von
uns